you
pilot to Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
visibility is [ __ ] zero - [ __ ] do
you understand me
pilot to Bombardier
control tower take the plane down take
the plane down
[Applause]
pilot the [ __ ] bomb but did you
thought I was [ __ ] m.i.a Uncle Joe is
always something less [ __ ] [ __ ] Mike
will sama bin Laden back in the [ __ ]
day you got a little cave every once in
a while and keep these [ __ ] in
check there's a late moon you could be
getting this on Australia on London
[ __ ] Singapore Hong Kong coming at
you like a [ __ ] you understand
me uncle Joey here creeping while you're
sleeping and peep them while you're
[ __ ] doing whatever the [ __ ] your
dorm it's late night Sunday Monday
morning I'm chomping at the [ __ ] peep
you understand now I'm ready to [ __ ]
go the malls a big [ __ ] day I'm gonna
sit with Gentiles and break it down from
I gotta tell you [ __ ] he's
gotta go here there
and direct traffic driver boss what I
would put up with an IP won't put up
with some [ __ ] boss hey listen it's
Monday morning as far as I'm concerned
grab your boss salute the [ __ ] Flag
this is your [ __ ] week [ __ ]
chosen what's with the [ __ ] chitter
chatter let's get down to business
we got a couple stars than me my salmon
I'm gonna make a protein shake tonight
you know how we [ __ ] him do it I wrote
I would you teach it to class spend time
with the family remember that time with
your family not really a man I [ __ ] up
with my youth but listen I'm gonna come
back [ __ ] [ __ ] Stanley right now
[Applause]
what do you think we'll focus smoke on
it's late night the [ __ ] thing
fire Spanish flag oh [ __ ]
understand me get up close and personal
here see the full [ __ ] patois the
[ __ ] did they get deal all these [ __ ]
[ __ ] Harvey Hall models trying to
pull up some fake [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
gun get the [ __ ] out of here I got it
too good with you [ __ ] one time
we got all books without all hallways
I'm saying [ __ ] these [ __ ]
nice look at that straight from the
[ __ ] iron in the stabbing little dock
the police breathing some [ __ ] water
tip-top McCool's better than you anyway
it's gonna be a big [ __ ] week even if
it's gonna be a shitty week in history
it's gonna be a big week ago make things
[ __ ] happen
you're gonna mug the janitor something's
going down
you have a mother camera I used to
monthly gather my high score was Friday
night four volumes of his pocket over
Joe Mary's tremendous book we got love
time anyway
hey we are Sunday night well smoke and
don't wear everything out all weekend
amazing VIP get the [ __ ] out here you
probably call committee in your [ __ ]
mouth will destroy your [ __ ] mobile
and it's a copy the [ __ ] beautiful
you [ __ ] not some snow and farts and
dropping [ __ ] and take it within the
next level with this [ __ ] bugle on my
face
anyway that's it that's then I wanted to
check in with you keep down your [ __ ]
toes if you have to be in that you like
jellies in Harlem if the [ __ ] I'm
doing crystal [ __ ] no I'm smoking reefer
trying to fight the proposal for the
[ __ ] book my man Gordon helping me
out then [ __ ] to put me on the right
track and now [ __ ] 3/4 is dead to me
putting your right arm up and you're a
kid you're finding your mother you don't
say it's kind of tough for a few days
you got a smoke pot and build up the
[ __ ] cheap Joey what's with this
cheat [ __ ] this Chinese enough now got
real bug deal by you [ __ ] come on you
think I'm not sharp with one gun with
two [ __ ] bullets on this job will
showing up the door birthday we're doing
that with them [ __ ]
Jesus everything I'm trying
you people date them he's [ __ ] around
here yeah you think I'm all these
[ __ ] dude you see I'm looking ass
with you baby alone all right
I'm about me and that dear
tremendous you think enjoy whisker
[ __ ] bugs they tapped they couldn't
take the reefing oh ho every morning I
come well wake up the before [ __ ]
bugs on my thing from a little white
flag with tap with don uncle Joey you
[ __ ] killed us remember what I told
you I don't need no [ __ ] no you don't
need to walk on no [ __ ] bricks and
I'm like that those [ __ ] stupid
Gentiles you need to join Scientology
the only allergy you need to join its
local Joey's ball allergy you understand
me grab your [ __ ] balls and get out
there who the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
what God made you special get out there
you [ __ ] you want to be a lawyer be a
lawyer you want to be a doctor be a
doctor you only be a professional
concept with kneepads [ __ ] be my
guest I'm gonna [ __ ] talk bad about
you I want you to go out there and do
what the [ __ ] you're supposed to do like
fries and I just said
the [ __ ] that he said see you guys get
me stole his [ __ ] and then you want me
to [ __ ] drop knowledge I get for
[ __ ] money what is a man what has he
got if not himself then he has naught
[ __ ] picadillo becoming body on a
Sunday night if I'm not [ __ ] fired up
by Gorilla Monsoon
look at that I'm sorry
I'm gonna wake up you're probably on the
couch rubbing rubbing your girlfriend's
feet like a [ __ ] book
you know my tality Stella's got
McDonnell he spells gotta go we either
gotta [ __ ] get them anyway
Who am I to talk about your girlfriend's
fittings and I got all [ __ ] up the
feet - I got a fungi now I can't get rid
of that person CBO around it I don't
know what the [ __ ] happened
and now the end is near and so I face
the final curtain are you [ __ ]
kidding me with your weird or lovable
can't do it shut the [ __ ] thing off
what we're doing a lot of them load it
up I'll give you a minute to let's
purify to really put the [ __ ] nail in
Jesus heart understand this is the one
that [ __ ] that dude smoked he shoved the
[ __ ] nice and Jesus idea watch this
[ __ ] from time to time Lex the hell are
you stabbing the cat yeah who needs that
aggravation I've been on probation now
what all [ __ ] time
Joey why you [ __ ] spawn here I got
[ __ ] to do
look at that nice tasteful [ __ ] room
but I thought all right this week after
school but after tomorrow we'd [ __ ]
think in front of maintain you don't
think it can't be gone up like
leadership a [ __ ] coughed up a
neck we swallow that they're great good
that's what happens if you want it so
Uncle Joe you're right that's what
happens I've been trying to tell you
[ __ ] but nobody believes me
and so I face the final and now you ever
just get [ __ ] stoned come on see what
I do is they were legit so nice when all
the [ __ ] the spirit blows novels out
I spent the stars in the night before
the whole [ __ ] thing like a blur all
over again the next day
the other sweater the t-shirts gotta be
where your honey's gonna be when you
need pads gotta be with the toffee you
borrow me your [ __ ] panties gotta be
wet that's what requires if it don't get
that wet the name those [ __ ] stars
intended yeah oh sorry I say Leroy it
aluminium bar upon Tara fever
it's Monday put your [ __ ] batteries
in we're talking about hangovers a
really good time at the beach of bad
[ __ ] actually you go in then you do
what you gotta [ __ ] do you understand
[ __ ] up but that was the coal correct
I think come out here to [ __ ] make
friends and talk about you know huh
Hillary I don't give a [ __ ] Marty will
you savages to get stunk to the [ __ ]
guilt
that's how I like it I don't know how
Casey like that that's the way I [ __ ]
like it alright anyway tomorrow night
podcast I love you [ __ ] with
all my heart
understand me stay black write your
goals drink your milk do your push-ups
and get ready for a [ __ ] fun-filled
week cuz we [ __ ] around this week me
oh I'm back like herpes
this [ __ ]